while people over 80 appear to be at
greatest risk from Kovan 19 infection
some of the opposite end of the age
spectrum are also vulnerable they're
hospitalized children with compromised
immune system that's led some Medical
Center's to limit the contact that these
young patients can have with their
families and obviously that can be
traumatic
Mireya Villarreal reports on what is
being done to both protect these
children and ease their emotional pain
Robyn Brazil is packing up and handing
out more than 80 prayer bears on her own
today
you are the last of the Mohicans that
there are no more volunteers yes I'm the
last one standing from a volunteer
standpoint that is here trying to get
the Bears out to the kids most of the
volunteers in the prayer bear program at
Cook Children's Hospital in Fort Worth
are over the age of 60 so for their
health and patient safety they were
asked to stay home why continue to
volunteer if you know there is a small
chance that you could get this as well
if I can do something to help a child or
a family through a crisis I'm willing to
continue to do this during this time
there are nearly 300 patients inside
Cook Children's main hospital many with
compromised immune systems they are part
of a vulnerable group highly susceptible
to the corona virus we FaceTime with
ten-year-old Ella plan T for her
hospital room she needed a bone marrow
transplant after being diagnosed with
aplastic anemia a rare autoimmune
disease that cripples her ability to
fight infections what has been the
hardest part about dealing with this
copán 19 concerns escalate hospital
administration decide to scale back on
patient visitors now only two primary
care givers are allowed inside even
siblings must stay out Jil Clause
families
port services director says security is
tight and social distancing is mandated
we are living in a coronavirus world
right now so so that has impacted what
you do here at the hospital we are
having two separate families which is
really hard we have a rule now that
siblings can't come up to visit and so
we're trying to be creative and how we
keep them is connected to keep connected
cooks is ramping up in house activities
like their interactive television
programs recognizing that they still
need to play that they still need to do
all those normal kid things it's amazing
how when kids start to interact and
engage and do things that are expressive
for them how they start to feel better
for now volunteer programs are on hiatus
in an effort to keep exposure to kovin
19 at bay hard to bear for longtime
volunteers like Robin I'll just wait for
the word when we can gear up again and
get back to doing what we do for CBS
this morning Saturday midday of Yahoo
Fort Worth Texas I can't even imagine
what it would be like right now to be a
five-year-old kid fighting cancer having
to do it alone not being able to see
family and having spent some time at
some of those children's hospitals it's
so important for the kids and the
families to have that connection and
also to have sometimes the distraction
of other people around that this is
making their battle twice as hard on the
flip side of that people in elderly
homes right now who can tame things
aren't taking visitors right now it is
awful use the communication the devices
that we can I guess is what people need
to do right now and we as we saw in that
piece time group FaceTime whatever else
whatever it takes